bonjour à faire rougir un bonjour
monsieur viol ton merci d'être avec nous
en tant que candidat à la députation
dans le centre atlantique sous les
couleurs socialistes comme expliqué
raphaël vaugirard que les socialistes
actuels vont pouvoir mal à la présidence
majoritaire à l'assemblée nationale
n'est que seuls candidats en martinique
pour le mois de juin prochain
allons monsieur vers le temps alors
avant de répondre à votre question je
voudrais souhaiter des choses en amont
technique mes concitoyens mes
compatriotes c'est tout d'abord la santé
parce c'est très important
et puis deuxièmement je veux aussi
souhaité l'optimiser parce que lorsqu'on
aborde la vie de manière pessimiste on
ne voit que des problèmes tandis que
lorsqu'on aborde sous l'angle de
l'optimisme on ne voit que des souris ch
alors je suis optimiste parce que c'est
optimiste réaliste
seul candidat il ya quatre
circonscriptions alors une loge e par
votre question notre fédération
socialiste 1 comporte treize sections et
il se trouve que c'est dans la
circonscription du centre que nous avons
le plus de section et de bonnes sections
qui fonctionne en conséquent il a été
c'était logique pour l'un d'eux de nous
appuyer sur ses forces pour aller à la
bataille mais c'est pas logique un grand
parti comme le voc n'est personne
d'ailleurs
non mais écoutez tremblé dans la section
du nord nll avant que deux sections et
qui dont deux qui sont elles ont en
dormance dans le sud nous avons
également des sections mail encore et ne
sont pas suffisamment dynamiques et puis
il faut qu'il y ait des candidats qu'ils
soient prêts à se lancer dans la
bataille parce que ce n'est pas une
petite histoire c'est un vrai engagement
conséquent vous sentirez seul monsieur
non mais j'ai l'habitude monsieur la
bataille il y aurait une machine avec
vous nous allons nous allons concentrer
nos forces nous aller dans le centre
atlantique c'est conscription alfred
marie-jeanne ne se présente pas c'est
une vraie opportunité une sorte de parc
bas à ne pas hésiter à enjamber comme le
reconnaissait josette manin
non pas du tout pour non socialiste il
faut savons que initialement la
circonscription c'est s appelait le nom
atlantique qui portait de trinité ou
monde et
si joseph était grande et puis monsieur
jean cousine de menus 9h amputé la la
circonscription et la roue est découpé
en faisant un intégrant le lamentin en
intégrant le robin et lefrançois qui
étaient traditionnellement insultes par
conséquent c'est tout le travail qu'il
faut refaire et puis nous avions dans la
circonscription de north atlantic
l'habitude de travailler sur des sujets
très lourd ou tel que la banane tels que
la question du chlordécone et d'autres
choses encore le vieillissement de la
population tandis que là maintenant il
faut ou recommencer le travail donc par
la section est notamment déjà la 12e
circonscription
si angers direction maryvette ainsi
représente pas il y aurait également
josette manin ancien président de
conseil général ex partenaire d'ensemble
pour d'autres nouvelles partenaires
plutôt d'un simple une martinique
nouvelle et ça ne vous gêne pas ça oui
je dois l'avouer que ça vienne parce que
madame agnès et une collègue bon on
s'entend très bien
mais il se trouve que nous n'avons pas
les mêmes intérêts politiques elle dit
rester un symbole mythique nouvelle
idiotie
oui j'y étais j'ai aimé mais je vous
fais remarquer que le 7 novembre 2015
losc ont présenté la liste mais d'amener
à aux fusées de participer dans les
personnalités elle était ça s'est passé
aux gourmands mais elle est restée dans
les tribunes
par conséquent nous nous allons punir
les nôtres on parlait de marche de
machines avec vous dans le secteur il ya
un certain mr à trinity qui s'appelle
frédéric buval également patricia tels
qu'ils conseillère à l'assemblée de
martinique ces deux sociation de
socialiste a plongé de la fédération
vous êtes comme en avait que deux alors
écoutez je vais vous faire une
confidence j'ai rencontré mon mon
camarade
il faut donc buval qu'est ce qu'il a dit
qu est ce qu ils disent non mais je vais
vous dire il m'a dit la chose suivante
il m'a dit qu'il est socialiste
pour moi ça me suffit monsieur viol
temps je n'ai pas besoin d'eux je n'ai
pas
je n'ai pas voulu pas lu par sa fille
non non je n'ai pas rencontré conseil du
bon vieux puisque nous sommes collés gap
non mais on n'a pas eu l'occasion de
discuter pour que je puisse savoir
exactement comment envisager une
campagne sous une bannière socialiste
alors que dans le même temps une autre
bataille la présidentielle se déroule
une campagne qui n'excite pas vraiment
le grand public nettement moins cette
audience par exemple pour le débat de
dimanche dernier par rapport au premier
débat c'est difficile de faire campagne
même pour cette élection législative
dans ce contexte un nous n'avons pas les
mêmes données monsieur viol temps parce
que précisément si le premier débat
était effectivement le lancement d'un
des primaires le deuxième débat à un net
succès et on n'oublie pas qu'on a
troisième prévue jeudi
par conséquent on a une montée en
puissance dans les lois de chiffres de
la primaire de la doite à lomé écouter
les chiffres nous disent que si nous
atteignons 3 millions 30 millions sek
bon ça sera déjà un excellent en
excellence b n'oubliez pas que pour les
punir de la doite beaucoup de directeurs
de gauche s'étaient avait participé pour
anticiper à l'élimination de s'imposer
enfin vous gérez votre programme en ce
qui concerne cette élection législative
il fois élu cité si tel était le cas
vous feriez quoi vous attaquent leur y
est directement à cette question de la
gouvernance de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique ce qui pose
beaucoup de questions aujourd'hui
alors tout d'abord je dois rappeler ce
que quelle est la mission du député
le député le mot député veut dire
missionné ces salons en utilisant un
taux et à travers député débuté mais ça
veut dire quelqu'un qui a une mission
alors la première mission député c'est
de représenter son pays vous représentez
la martinique à l'assemblée nationale et
autant que possible dans un grand groupe
où l'on peut s'exprimer où on peut
exposer des problèmes on peut exiger des
choses vous revendiquez et par
conséquent nous socialistes nous avons
un groupe qui sera au minimum 250 débuté
en vous
forum antique monsieur marc j'étais dans
un petit groupe de moins de 50 députés
par conséquent il était moins audible
par conséquent en tant que socialiste je
pense que si la victoire mais ce oui je
veux penser qu'un grand groupe pour
reposer vos schémas pour avoir la chance
d'être entendu c'est ce que vous dites
aux martiniquais sonata bain
deuxièmement le député aussi revendiqué
de quoi ils risquent au repos pour nous
pour nous dans les politiques publiques
qui sont appliqués à nohant nos
territoires
un autre territoire proposé aussi des
politiques proposé d'aider des solutions
moi par exemple pour une enseigne que la
peau pour inverser la tendance
par exemple les quantités de jeunes que
nous avons qui sont clés qui sont
désireuses zanon sentir la relance du
service militaire à huy rendement je
vous le dis très clairement
- là l'une des premières choses que je
vais revendiqué c'est que l'on vit
ensemble passe à prix fort sinon sa
visibilité on va les envoyer se battent
en syrie en irak ou en afghanistan
mais ce sens civique où ils vont
apprendre ça existe et le service
civique c'est nous mais il n'est pas
obligatoire n'est pas attendant on
pourra proposer à nos jeunes de faire de
l'humanitaire de dalé et des dents au
regard des pour les enfants nés en haïti
l'odieux du tremblement de terre de 2010
des centaines de mentalités sont partis
pour aider à sauver des vies à aider les
haïtiens après en face à cette
catastrophe naturelle
et puis d'autres choses encore par
exemple par isabelle adouci qui est en
ce moment sur la loi sur l'égalité
réelle des chances ou au sénat
majoritairement à droite on semble
détricoter ce qui était fait par
l'assemblée nationale belge entièrement
socialiste je vous remercie de la poser
cette question en banque et qui dilate
eux
cette actualité parce que précisément
l'égalité réelle
ce n'est pas une loi d'assimilation
comme certains veulent le faire croire
c'est une boîte à outil qui permet à nos
collectivités à nos territoires de
contractualiser avec l'état ce qu'on
appelle des plans de convergence et des
contraintes de convergence et bien sûr
en passant nous allons aligner un
certain nombre de prestations sociales
telles que bon le complimenter enfin
millien le tout les allocations pour
retraitement parce que j'avais il ya
beaucoup de différentiel entre ce qui
appliqué chez nous par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient fait campagne sur ce que
proposait des socialistes au
gouvernement
alors donc on va aligner sa main pour
sortir de la fameuse parité globale que
la doite nous proposer des équipements
avec universel du smic et tout et tout
donc nous allons finalement aligné les
prestations mais donner des outils
nouveaux les outils nouveaux c'est le
contrat de convergence et le plein de
gouaille aux non contractualisés
directement avec l'état et en intégrant
d'autres dispositifs tels que par
exemple et là les questions
institutionnelles
les questions des fonds européens les
deux entreprises dont vous allez
reprendre des thèmes proposés par son
regard de l'envolée temps nous dit dites
nous ce que vous voulez faire
quel est votre projet et nous vous
accompagnons nous faisons le point avec
vous et nous mettons les moyens avec des
contrôles d'organismes d'état tels que
la chambre régionale des comptes la fin
de votre accueil comptez vous dire non
mais je n'ai pas fini mais il nous reste
encore deux minutes à peine deux minutes
sur ce volet tant réclamée par le
secteur de l'économie la défiscalisation
qu'est ce que vous diriez là dessus
alors pour la défiscalisation
j'ai lu récemment le rapport de monsieur
bernard castagnet de haut niveau et qui
expliquait la chose suivante il dit que
c'est un outil extrêmement puissant et
qui maintenant se pérennise un wording
depuis mais sans risque puisque à chaque
gouvernement qui arrive on retourne et
corrigée et sait désormais avec les
difficultés budgétaires de l'état on a
tendance à rogner sur les le niveau
d'exonération auquel se relève
la visibilité aux pèlerins sur les
lèvres de la pédagogie n'a été qu'en
alors que moi je pourrai pour vous et
c'est précisément dans le cadre de
contrats de convergence proposer à nos
entreprises avec le temps d'avoir de
stabiliser la défiscalisation et
d'introduire un élément nouveau c'est à
dire facilité non pas non seulement
l'investissement mais le riz
investissement j'ai visité une
entreprise aux gones royal est ça qui
fait que nous sommes si le feront en
matière agroalimentaire et bien voilà
une entreprise qui fait du
réinvestissement qui utilisent abolition
non seulement la défiscalisation mais
les fonds nous voir et nous importe
c'est pas toujours ça l'esprit de la
défiscalisation ce sont des gens
d'ailleurs qui viennent à nos îles ça
c'est ça c'est le goûter ni à l'eau
alors le problème
un avantage de la l'égalité réelle c'est
qu'officiellement on peut localiser
cette politique d'aller dans l'outre-mer
et non pas avec des dés bénéficiant
métropolitain merci d'avoir été ça avec
nos rafale rougir on rappelle que vous
êtes candidat de la fédération et de
martinique à la députation dans la
centre atlantique bonne journée